I heard this though I heard that Korean
women are switching over to Chinese
husbands so yeah because the children's
husband is easy to manipulate
Sharp
what other men are easy to manipulate
the Jewish boys yeah yeah I like them
because like they are trained by their
mom so when I abuse them they feel like
home
are you married
um as they left they both left
really that's so epic
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way go to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday you guys
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show go to neutrifold.com
and enter code trash to save ten dollars
off your first month's subscription get
ten dollars off at nutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
free shipping on every order offer
available to us customers for a limited
time hi slugs I'm doing stand-up comedy
and I will be in Miami Boston New York
um and a bunch of other places you can
get tickets at Esther onice.com hello
sluggies
um welcome to this episode of trash
Tuesday and also I am here on the set of
Annie wood my new solo podcast we have
20 episodes down we've had amazing
guests it's been so fun the show is
growing it's special it's Unique and I
think you guys will like it so check it
out if you haven't already it's every
Thursday at 9 00 a.m Pacific Time noon
Eastern we love you so come see us you
can also see me live
I will be in Toronto April 21st and 22nd
I'll be in Raleigh North Carolina May
12th and 13th if you came out to my
shows in Greensboro you're going to want
to come to Raleigh too it's going to be
a different vibe those were wild ones
I'll be in Baltimore at magoobies June
2nd and 3rd I'll be in Salt Lake City
Utah Wise Guys Club June 9th and 10th
and then I'll be in Calgary with the
Great Outdoors Comedy Festival with
Andrew Schultz August 27th a lot more
dates are being added so go to
annieleterman.com shows enjoy the show
[Music]
thank you
hey you guys
um uh welcome to another episode of
trash Tuesday I'm sweating because I
think this is the first time I've been
this late ever well we so yes today was
crazy we are recording this at a special
time because we had to get this queen in
here oh thank you for having me you guys
are the queen thank you for being here
you're a hilarious stand-up comedian
you're so funny on Instagram on Tick
Tock and then wait hang on we'll talk
about it in a sec but everybody it's
Zhao Ying Summers wow that's my name and
you said perfectly I feel I'm glad you
said it challenging Summers thank you
it's not that hard yeah it's it's not
hard but it's not the be how how is the
J pronounced so is it more like a softer
like a like
a child like a jungle River
it's not that hard yeah thank you
because you are smart
yeah most people can't say it thank you
for for doing this I'm so happy to be
here I love your show I'm just my
assistant's screaming she's a huge fan
she's screaming right now she's a white
girl she's uh
I love that you said two husbands left
you because I really relate to that I've
never had a husband but men do leave me
often yeah they just they leave because
they realize the real me is not
something they want
is take sometimes it takes a few weeks
sometimes it takes years but they
eventually get it wait marijuana leave
like on Tuesday well how long did each
last what's the first one he uh he uh we
are called your sweethearts it lasts
like seven six seven years because
ningley we were not living together so
he didn't really see who I am and that's
a big thing when you live together with
someone that's when it all comes yeah
yes so my second husband is the comedy
thing that he can let me do comedy he
won't let me his uh he's a he's a
management from High that's why when
people tell me to stop Asian hate I'm
like not all of them you have to hit a
Chinese man they need all the hate they
suck they are cheap and disgusting
yeah wait wait a second my my first real
boy that I was like obsessed with
um was a Taiwanese boy I swear to God if
he asked me to marry him today I still
would but I found him to be like just
the [__] greatest guy like even to
this day I look at his Instagram I'm
like [__]
yeah the Chinese the Chinese I mean the
the mainland China or Taiwanese Hong
Kong guy they are taught to basically to
spoil women like a woman is always right
that's the if you believe in woman's
rights you also have to believe woman's
always right
[Laughter]
together in China which is I think it's
the same as the Jewish boys
right you have nice tits thank you so
much oh my God you are like a Japanese
porn star this is
really is I always say she's like a 12
year old Japanese boy but with big tits
yeah she's like a anime yeah a little
anime Japanese porn and she's so petite
but she's so curvy like she has a big
butt oh my and her waist is this but
she's got like a
just go get naked and kiss we should
you're like you're like a very a young
Sky Johansson like
right yes a young body tired yeah a
young one same phase two young High
School husband oh my God yes I can cook
I can I can cook I can clean but I can
cook
I I tend to date Jewish guys
um I think that they usually have a
really good relationship with their mom
and that just helps I think that makes
them like more loving Partners I not go
the other direction too though where
it's like now like Mom no where it's
like Mommy did everything for me so yeah
now I want you to do everything for me
yeah in fact there's so many Jews I I
think if you're a tall Jewish guy you're
vile like those are the worst there's
some that come to mind I won't say their
names
um
but um yes I think some Jewish men are
absolutely horrible and they just think
that every woman belongs to them and
it's a mess so you do are there bad
Chinese men oh my yeah my ex um
yeah they just it's well they can like
when we met you'd be like he was like I
want you to you know pursue your dream I
want to be supportive and then he's just
going to slowly try to make you feel
crazy for wanting her career it's a slow
burn it's like slowly slowly slowly yeah
he just sounds like a con man because he
just basically he appeared one way in
the beginning I feel like also those
kind of men like they always want a
strong woman to break her down they
don't want to break down Amber from
Starbucks
because like a like Chris Brown like you
you want Rihanna like then you you know
that's just like the power to be with a
woman who's strong and then you start
guessing at her be like having talent is
bad because I mean what is even it's not
a game unless she is like something big
to break I think so because if yeah
you're right if it's like sweet Amber
from Starbucks like what the game will
last one day it's too boring it's not
challenging it's not yeah no this is
real I've literally heard confirmed that
like a guy
like didn't like that the girl he was
with was happy because he was jealous so
he tried to make her not happy
Jesus Christ isn't that [__] sick
that is sick like this stuff is real
it's not in our heads we're not yeah the
worst thing we can do to somebody as a
woman is to be happy about our body and
who we are that pissed off people so
much like like when you imagine I'm like
I love my skin card I really love it I
think my husband just had a heart attack
he's like
what did you say
like it's just crazy if we love
ourselves yeah they'll try to like yeah
a lot we'll like knock you down yeah
they hate it yeah see I don't have that
issue with Dave but I think that's
because he knows that I'm never going
anywhere so he doesn't have to knock me
down to keep me
just like Esther has never broken up
with a boy
she's always been the dumpy are you the
same well they they do awful things for
me to say that I want to leave but
basically their thumb is me you know
what I'm saying like yes they play the
game like they are done with me and
they're like don't leave but don't talk
to me for months I'm like
so I have to like
oh are we done
yeah they trick you and yeah they trick
you into be like for me to
to be the bad person they're like oh
it's done but I know it's been it's been
done for a while yeah are you currently
a single uh I am seeing somebody but I'm
just trying to uh focus on my career
because the career don't leave you I
mean I don't have a career yet but I
guess you do or you can thank you my mom
says that I was wearing this she's like
you don't have a glazed donut I'm like
you see what she's like oh uh just I'm
just kidding you're a fat but you're not
sweet you are not a donut
it's bad like there is some like an
Asian haters start from my house my name
my mate she's an Asian Chinese woman I
was working in bed she's like your face
look very yellow as the because I'm
Chinese
you know you look tired I mean like what
do you mean it's like you look you are
aging I'm like what do you want she's
like you are drinking chicken soup right
now I said I don't want chicken soup
it's like wow you don't have a choice
your husband left you you wanna drinking
chicken soup but you're gonna get weaker
and older and you can't get any man you
can't even pay my pay me anymore so you
have to eat the chicken soup
I said thank you
I wouldn't wear yellow
I'm like this is a bathroom which I
don't wear that it looks so yellow
because yellow is like in Chinese
culture it's like your face look yellow
you look tired
well in like white people culture is
just jaundice right yeah yeah liver
failure yeah liver food I wear hepatitis
one of one of the liver function but
um it's bad what is that though like is
that just an Asian thing like we're so
hard on each other like I'm Filipino and
it's like you know that right it's it
they're cruel it's like what did my
niece just got a haircut and it was a
really cute haircut but she did it at
home and my mom comes over and the first
thing she says is like like you look
horrid like you look so bad why did you
do that and my niece is 21 and I talked
to my mom was like you can't talk to her
like that she's like yeah I can it's
like it looks bad so I'm gonna tell her
it looks bad I was like but [__] like
what is this need for us to be so like
cruel especially if you're like in the
same family yeah I I think it's it's
very natural I was going to my mom
doesn't think I made anything happen in
my life and but when I'm spending money
that's she she'll try to sweet talk me
out of it I was going to uh see my
therapist I said I at 2PM I'm gonna go
she said what do you do as we talk and
remember how much money she pay you I'm
like what she's like my daughter have
too many followers and people pay her to
talk to her I'm like no I have followers
and people pay me yeah yeah how much
they pay I said no Mom I I pay her she
goes no you can talk to me for free
I said mom you're the reason why I need
a therapy I can't talk to you anymore
I would really fit in I love being
treated like [__] I love when people
tell me I look bad like I like honestly
I don't want you guys but it's not even
honesty it's almost like they're just
trying to us like verbally assault you
as a hobby I just like Asian culture
they still believing in being very very
humble and like it's attractive future
for women that's why I feel like they
had learned to do that to us so we are
not like I'm the best we are not like
being like I look good this because in
Asia that's very unattractive right it's
like like a to be a strong woman to be
to to feel herself yeah like it's very
like great like even sexy and cute if a
girl is like Meek and shy yes and not
and and is kind of like tentative yes
and Afraid okay I have a question is it
a red flag if a white guy is like coming
for either of you like or do you feel
like oh my God I'm just a fetish they
just want like a submissive
um I don't like it I don't mind if a guy
dates me like a white guy say for
instance I I don't like it when he's
like you know I only date brown girls
like you then it's like oh like this is
a thing you're proud of but it's kind of
like icky at the same time because
you're targeting just one and so that's
when it becomes a little fetishite yeah
and also like some guys they don't talk
about it but you look at their
ex-girlfriend dying off ladies
like what why like why
why how do you like suss that out if
you're just like a fetish to them or
they just want someone subservient
because that's like that what the I I
feel like if every single girlfriend is
Chinese there's more than five of them
are 90 80 100 Chinese I think is weird I
don't mind it I just I would never I
just feel like it's a fetish and then
they would really want you to be because
I'm not behaving like a Chinese girl I'm
the Chinese girl no no Chinese mom like
once you know I'm yeah I'm in the bed
I'm like the awful awful like if a white
guy want a Chinese girl and they found
me they'll be like oops whoops they'll
leave me like in the morning they'll be
like I gotta go okay this is maybe like
sketchy and controversial but is it okay
for me to dislike men who only want to
date Asian women I think it's okay
that's called a yellow fever they have
yellow fever like all Asia files Asia
files yeah yeah I think it's a red flag
I think it's like that they're just want
a submissive woman like I know this guy
who moved to Japan and like started his
life over there and I just and like then
when I I once went to a dinner with him
and he didn't look at me the whole
dinner only looked at the men and only
spoke to the men and I'm like what is
going on what is this is weird right
he's a samurai like it became like an
easy Tom Cruise wouldn't you become a
Samurai look at women they are dogs
she's like what the [__] going on yeah
but I'm like I don't I feel like it's
not something that's really appropriate
to speak about because I don't want to
be like Oh I'm it seems like I don't
like men who like Asian women but I it's
there's something going on there I think
yeah they they're definitely something
going they're fetishizing an idea of an
Asian woman they are not fetishizing
joeying or me because we are girls who
are a little bit we don't conform to the
idea they have in their head so it's
almost like they fetishize this idea
that there is this submissive woman who
will be this you know domesticated queen
that someone that who's just going to
you know be at his beck and call all and
so that's I think that most guys that go
for Asian women have that like fixed in
their head like they kind of paint us
all with like yes and I'm like oh big
mistake I'm like [__] I'm like a bull
you know yeah like also like if I ask
you to choke me when you [__] me you
don't I'll [__] smash you on the face
get out get out I guess like in my 20s I
dealt with something similar where
people I never realized it until people
brought it up but like I looked pretty
young and dressed pretty young people
were like oh Esther if guys like you
they're pedophiles and so I that you
know I deal with that I I can feel it
though right like I would want like I
was going this with this guy like he was
like you look you're dressing too old to
mature I'm like I'm 33. I'm expired by
Leonardo's standard like I'm done like
I'm a camera fish I'm done like it's
expired I'm I'm 33 like I'm just that's
it you know he want me to wear something
like a really young and cute and I'm
like I'm not cute I was never cute
I was never killed in China I was always
dressed like a boy like a boy because
it's you you are from Asia you know
colorism is the worst thing ever like
the colorism yeah everywhere across the
board I would say like but I think in
East Asia in the Philippines people wear
bleaching skin right so like yeah what
she's saying basically is whitening
products are probably one of the biggest
selling cosmetic anything over there
like and colorism is not just a oh like
Chinese versus Filipino even in the
Filipino Community there's colorism so
do you have light-skinned Filipinos and
dark-skinned Filipinos more in like the
north let's say for instance who are
looked down upon because they have the
broader nose they have the certain
features that aren't considered like the
standard for beauty in Asia and what I
find even more troubling for me in the
Philippines now is that because of like
the Korean invasion in the Philippines
now the Korean soft Beauty standard is
what is praise in the Philippines and
you're like dude we're Filipino like
we're brown skin we have our certain set
of features but now everyone is going
for that same API yeah the soft look and
the boys are starting to look softer and
softer and you're like what the [__]
everyone looks like a [__] kdrama now
yes oh my God it is so bad like I I I
was too dark for East Asia standard I
was not allowed to wear a dress I said I
want a pink dress my sister had Mama try
it I went to school in the other he'll
still rock on me they would like go back
to Africa oh my God
the Asians handle their own hate we we
have the Asian hate Club is going on
strong like you know and also like in
China they look down on the Philippines
but not all of them but I like to
address the problems because Asia is not
one country we have our problems and we
have to talk about it like you know it's
people get Illustrated they think
everybody's Chinese they hate Chinese so
much so the Koreans and the Japanese are
getting hate go back to China I'm from
Japan
Japan is in China you know yeah it's bad
it's off and in the Philippines we have
like one of the biggest like Asian
migrations really early on was Chinese
so we call them Phil chai and they are
usually like wealthy like they're
usually of the wealthier families like
back home
um but yeah it's kind of a crazy thing
how if you live in America you don't
necessarily know how bad we all hate
each other back there totally and also
the Filipino women are the most
beautiful because they have the most in
this world Miss Universe seriously these
are the Earth
something but I have a theory about this
that um my world standard Filipino are
the most beautiful people I feel like
they are the perfect mixture but in the
west but who did what kind of girls do
they send to Miss Universe they're the
girls who are half like me when have
they really sent like a real there's one
Venus raw was one of them she was like a
dark skin Filipina girl but that was
like the only one yeah all the others
have white last names yeah they kind of
look half like me and another thing is I
think one of the reasons that we always
win Miss Universe are always in the top
five is for Ratings I think whoever is
up there knows that the 150 million
people 150 million Filipinos are going
to tune into the Miss Universe Pageant
because we know yeah we speak English
and another like we are so obsessed with
pageant culture and I think they want to
keep the viewership up until the top
five and they know Filipinos are gonna
watch and tune in so they put the girl
Miss Philippines always in the top five
that's just the theory I think it's very
smart oh my God that was just she's
smart I know wait I want to do could we
do like Miss podcasts and have a beauty
pageant what would our talents be what
would you what would our talent be I
don't think Miss Universe has a talent
thing anymore but yeah it's just
swimsuit and like evening gown that's so
unfair and sad it's like we don't even
want want to let you have any kind of
dreams or like just just stand there in
a bikini that's all we care about but
Miss USA does I'll be missing
mispronunciation
I think I would tap dance if I was in a
beauty pageant but you're a dancer you
already have that right yeah but like
that's like I could do a monologue or oh
that's you're gonna win what about you
well actually I was in a beauty pageant
2014 as Miss China for this
International beauty pageant in La
called the Queen of the Universe and
yeah I am I have a penis
um it was just it's a beauty pageant you
know like I was wearing a dress and
somebody's like this dress is made in
China I'm like this pageant is made in
China it's not even a pageant like it's
not miss world like I can wear apron
like I don't care do they have you do
Talent yeah I didn't have any but um I
did try it's more the dancing and in
that that thing which I can't do but I
can tell jokes but they didn't have that
yes
there'd be like a girl with wit nothing
yeah
disqualified oh yeah I know he's like a
comedy in the 40s if you are a pretty
girl you just gonna get on stage and you
sing or you put a rabbit out of the
Adobe assistant of the magician you
don't even expect you to be funny like
it's just like not allowed
Lila what would your talent be I don't
know like hey guys come you know come
sit around a swimming pool and watch me
swim like that's the only talent I have
is like physical like athleticism what
about like a lap dance that could be a
good time
I mean if you were the judge yes because
I know I would immediately win but um no
like I think that I I don't have that I
don't have the dance but nothing I
literally have no talent that is so what
animal facts let me spit some animal
facts wait howler monkeys yeah that's
all I know is like and Wildlife trivia I
feel like that actually would be the
most like the biggest turn on like like
it's like a student teacher thing like
you're teaching everybody I don't know
we could try sometimes at home we do
Professor Dave where Dave teaches me
about something sexy yeah I need to do
some foreplay wait what does he teach
you though like basically if we're
having a random conversation and I'm
like I no I don't know anything about
that war and then I'll be like Professor
Dave and then he'll just like get a
little bit more formal and teach me more
about it it's actually not sexual at all
well what Bobby and I used to do this
really sick one of of the many sick ones
we used to do but one of them was that I
was a refugee from like the Philippines
and he was the white man saving me he
was a Tom Cruise so you are Pocahontas
yeah he's like oh and he would like SWAT
the flies from my face he'd be like oh
you poor girl and he's like you want
food and I'm like I'm so hungry and he
was like you want to try this you know
and he's like there's calories in him
like there are give it to me oh my God
that's hot yeah wait you know my
ultimate ultimate role play Fantasy is
like being a Jewish girl and like the
Nazi Soldier like saving me to [__] me
foreign
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forget about and
chances are you're one of them like that
stars app just to watch one show or that
free gaming trial you never actually use
rocket money will quickly and easily
find your subscriptions for you and for
any you don't want to pay for anymore
just hit cancel and Rocket money will
cancel it for you it's that easy rocket
money also helps you manage all of your
finances in one place and automatically
categorizes your expenses so you can
easily track your budget in real time
and also get alerted if anything looks
off
over three million people have used
rocket money saving the average person
up to 720 dollars a year you guys that
is so much money stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going through rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday
rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday
so kalila Annie and I just re-upped our
neutral orders we were all talking about
it this weekend and you guys we don't
agree on a lot but we agree on one thing
and that is neutral neutral women is
ideal if you're experiencing thinning
hair caused by stress dieting over
styling and environmental toxins while
women's balance is formulated with
additional hormone support for those
with thinning hair through menopause
and you should visit neutrifold.com and
take their hair Wellness quiz for a
personalized product recommendations
that are unique to your hair's needs and
healthier hair growth takes time you'll
begin to experience thicker stronger
faster growing hair in three to six
months
neutriful is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness
and visible scalp coverage you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to neutrophone.com and
entering promo code trash to save ten
dollars off your first month
subscription this offer is only
available to you as customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order get 10 off at neutrophil.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
[Music]
um so you grew up in China and when did
you come to the states uh 2009 I came
here I was 18. 18. yes and were you
what's what's China's like one child
policy now uh now it's good you can have
more kids but the major problem is like
one child policy nobody want baby girls
yeah you know there's this gender
problem there's no man there's less
woman so you can be an ugly [__]
if a girl you're ugly as [__] you have
four men chasing you because
there's
there's way more men than women and
during the when you were born say for
instance and they still had like the one
child policy at that time yeah like
would they
um like just dump the girls I don't I
don't like when Americans tell me they
just put the baby girl in the dumpsters
I'm like [__] heels they also put them
in the railway okay
it's like you can't just assume things
like that's what they do there's other
things too but like it's bad yeah people
uh want I know you are a Filipino they
want the boys they always carry the
family carry whatever they and then when
there's only one child is allowed they
want that child to be
a boy if he was born a girl if that baby
never existed you're gonna have one more
baby oh yeah is your first one yeah
because if you know because you have to
continue the link because the first baby
that the girl that died at Birth
I see him like really though for my joke
I honestly like the one child policy you
know that's
um peanuts only that's also called the
Michael Jackson policy baby boys only so
so when I was born my father asked my
mom where does she live my mom said I
think she will if you just bring her
back from the dumpster
so it's like will she live
it's dark and talking about it got me a
lot of trouble like I got canceled on
Tick Tock I I heard about that so you
hit one over one million followers and
then you got the platform yeah it was
her name was gong it's didn't exist
why because because it's political
well she talked you talked about the one
child policy basically and her jokes
basically became viral and they were
like because China is owned by I'm sorry
um Tick Tock is owned by China
um and so there was just this idea that
which I found interesting because they
censored you and then they put you back
on but then in a limited lawyer but in a
limited way still right yeah yeah I
don't I'm not getting the views I mean
I'm not getting the followers and Views
I used to have yeah so yeah is they are
monitoring me they're like this [__]
yeah she's that's um so I think the same
thing happened with Chelsea Lynn with
Instagram because once she hit a million
followers
um she got the platform or that the plot
they did they took her thing down and
then when she got it back up it's almost
like they have an extra eye on her
because even like the most minor
offenses they'll take her post down
almost immediately even if it's like a
nothing thing so I think they had just
have extra eyes on you it's [__] up
yeah no so does that mean that you're an
only child uh I my mom wants a boy so
bad she kept trying I have a younger
sister and younger brother she kept two
girls she lost her house and her job and
everything but she's like be okay wait
so she was allowed to have more than one
well you are but you are going to they
are going to find you so much that is
going to be the price of your house you
get fired from your job and even your
relatives who's like your assistant
brothers who has who uh who is like you
are my sister you decide to have one
more baby and I'm also getting fired
because I read it to you so it's just
that the pressure Financial pressure is
just like you can't you only have one
baby
so high risk yeah you'll have a girl
some people I could keep their girl you
know it's fine but it just people want a
boy they just want a boy yeah that's
like all across the board in like all
cultures yeah how about in American
culture
well I know my dad wanted a son because
he told me
um but
yeah I don't think I don't
I don't know it doesn't feel that
promise especially now it feels like
all the of the culture talks about it's
like guys are like the kind of the
problem in our society yeah I'm not
saying that other people are Professor
Scott Galloway yeah
um
but I I feel like now don't you think in
American culture people want to have
girls
I certainly do like if I think about
having a child and if I could pick and
choose like I absolutely like love the
idea of raising a daughter yeah I think
maybe it makes me nervous like Big Boy
energy makes me nervous but I've always
wanted a girl but only because I just
like want a best friend
but it seems like that actually for the
Mom it's better to have a boy you have a
better bond with your son as the rumors
out there yeah I think so that's my
daughter don't even look at me she don't
give me I can't tell my son just like my
mommy's so beautiful and funny my mom is
so beautiful my daughter just look at me
she showed her eyes I'm like Mom what's
going on with my daughter my mom said um
I I I'm gonna die someday and I don't
want to miss me so I'm training her to
hate you
wait but I recently read this article
that um they called it like the
Heartbreak of I don't know what the
article was called but it's basically
the Heartbreak of having sons and like
you have a very like finite time with
your son because when you they're very
close to you in the beginning they
become a mama's boy but boys don't come
back home and become friends with their
mom girls we always keep really close
relationships with our mom so this is
woman who talks about just having the
Heartbreak of knowing that her son will
just like kind of never be like around
as much anymore that sounds so hard
actually it's hard it's also very true
it is so true because the wife would be
the the priority of women which is good
that's good but yeah that sounds really
challenging like sometimes when I see
pictures of Dave when he was little I'm
like oh my God he's so cute like i s and
I feel like the love of his mom I'm like
I can feel what she must feel towards
him and then it makes me like want to
love him more because I'm like I have to
do it for her like that's her little
baby she's so beautiful that's so
beautiful but also most of the time I'm
like really mean so that's good yeah
uh I I feel like in Chinese casual we
say that the daughter is
um
the lover of the father from the past
life and the son is the lover of the mom
from the past life
it really makes sense that's a creepy
but also it makes sense creepy because
you didn't work out it's like it didn't
work out it's a love of your life but
you never end up together so now you
have a chance to have another
relationship that's also the closest but
it's not sexual it's not lovers but it's
all it's in a different Dynamic you can
love each other in a different way
yeah I mean it makes sense it makes
sense but I just would hate to think
that like my dad was you know my
ex-lover you know what I mean yeah
because in my past life right that would
that would be it right and then and your
your dad would be a lover in your past
life
wait we were nodding earlier like yup
yup
no I'm I'm like I'm lost I'm lost I
don't want to know but it's better than
I know sometimes I just go away and it's
good that's dissociating it's very it's
both unhealthy and unhealthy at the same
time how about like I wanted to have
like I'm like why is this my son not
LeBron James like wise wait how many
kids do you have I have two I didn't
learn from my mistakes um one boy one
girl yeah my son and my daughter my
boy's four my daughters too really yes
she's very cute so you're like you're in
the thick of it yeah I didn't learn like
I have two kids and I have a custody and
I'm a single mom my mother moved to from
China to America to help me raise the
kids after my divorce because I have to
do stand up I want to do it and I I need
my mom you know I can't my maid she's
gonna sell my son
[Laughter]
yeah she'll make my daughter her slave
working in the basement but she was down
my son so I know that through Michael
Jackson
so I I just I need my mom and you know
mom and daughter she would do anything
for me well she tell me if she would do
anything for me your mom yeah she she'll
tell me the truth I want to be a
comedian she's like
honey I don't know because not all ugly
people are funny
and also you know yeah it's that's
exactly it it's like the The Duality of
having a parent that like
um expresses love not in like a verbal
way like my mom she will come over and
clean like there isn't anything she
wouldn't do for me but [__] does she not
give it up like she's never like God
you're pretty God I love you God let me
hug you like none of that but the
necessary things that need to be done
she gets done and she's happy to so it's
like it's so conflicting in my heart
because I'm like do you love me do you
hate me yes is it both yeah if we are
mean to the man that's you know we don't
have a choice
play my mom for that you know I just
realized I think I have an Asian fetish
for Asian moms because I love the way
your mom talks to you and whenever I've
hung out with Olivia Munn's mom she's so
mean and I'm just like oh my God can
your mom come everywhere with us it's so
much fun I love it like that's my
comfort I don't know it's so mean it
becomes funny
it's so good it's become funny I just I
started just like I I want my mom say
something I said Mom I'll pay you for
this joke it's like my mom when my
ex-boyfriend is uh a short slightly
chubby Korean man but very cute but she
goes she's like my Bobby will be like
hey Ma Bubby you look like a ball a
bowling ball but without the holes like
just straight up like that's the first
thing she says to him and then he starts
to cry laughing and he like loves he
loves being roasted by my mom like
they're like like thick as thieves
that's amazing is that what you want yes
that's exactly what I want
will your mom make me dinner tonight she
will but she's gonna call you like a
dumb [__] at the same time that's you
know that's good that's what I'm looking
for oh my God my mom they should meet my
mom and your mom they should very abuse
her together and spoil her together too
would you would you not like absolutely
love that yeah that's exactly what I'm
looking for in life and I don't know why
but it's that's like it's hitting
something and my mom is yeah I was I was
running tracks when I was like a seven
years old because in China big lips is
ugly like it's disgusting they think
tiny lips are pretty so I I was running
tracks my friend she fell we both fell
and she broke her nose and I didn't
broke anything I was just like I'm so
flexible my mom's like yeah because your
lip touched the ground first
she just didn't she didn't even blink
she just I'm like oh so do you like so
does your mom live with you yeah and do
you like that that seems nice it's
because I don't need to try to find out
when I come home and when the babysitter
is coming I guess she's there full time
I have my maid who abuse me with her
together they just work together they
were like I wouldn't eat that rice I'm
like
is my husband back like who is this who
is this person like he's just they are
just so together on me and I'm just
sleeping and I work I work so hard so
they just like they don't bug me as much
but they'll say something like I'm like
I think I like this hat you know this
little break they're like I wouldn't
wear that I'm like why because your face
is an Asian persimmon face
[Laughter]
and then do you ever like do you what if
you like have a guy like what how do you
what do you are they are they just uh
they were they were like um I remember
my mom I had a boyfriend to come over
she she likes him she thinks he's very
cute she's she's like making picking dog
I'm like oh she's is he um um is he
Chinese is he an Asian guys is it is a
white guy who speaks some Chinese so
it's like my mom's like making the
picking duck I'm like Mama you never do
that like you do love him so much do you
think it's gonna work out she's like I
just want him uh you know when he leaves
you he remembers the food is good oh
yeah wait oh that's a point of Pride I
think yeah when he when he leaves
[Music]
wait so you came here when you were 18.
I'm hungry
foreign
[Laughter]
can I move in with you I just feel like
it would be fun to live there oh my God
yes please my mom's gonna love you
because she always wanted to become a
wet
girl's game with your eyes bigger like I
was 17. you carrying double eyelida
surgery I'm like why you wanted surgery
or you want no husband I'm like no
husband sounds good to me wait did you
get the double eyelid I had a one is a
double one is single my mom said let's
fix that fix it it's already let's just
make sure it's less problem so we we did
this one but this one become too big so
then I fixed that one again so
technically I I but it's like very
slightly it's not big I didn't try to
look
Filipino I I just want to like still
look like an Asian person like well it's
kind of crazy sometimes because I have
friends who get the double eyelids
looking cross-eyed because it kind of
opens it a little too much yes they want
to be as big as it can they want to be
westernized like you want to be
Westerner and they won't also put the
things in your nose to be taller so you
can have a bridge they add the bridge
okay so my mom won't you she want me to
become you if I look like you she'll be
so happy also because your face is not
like yeah you are literally the anime um
princess face like we would remove jaw a
ball bones to have v-shaped face you
have visha face you are getting the
penis the dicks and money everything you
have this fish you are you are yeah you
aren't getting nothing no so like my big
cheeks my like Jagged like jawline is
not cute in Asia you are a Filipino
Angela Jolie
you have two dumplings glue together
wait this is so crazy so I I've never
gotten any work done but I have explored
all of my options and I recently went in
for a consultation because I thought
that like there are some celebrities
that were getting this eye surgery that
was like making their eyes look more
open the bluff yes
and I went in and basically the doctor
was like
like I paid I paid 500 to get this
consultation and he's like I don't
understand he's like if I did that
surgery on you you wouldn't be able to
close your eyes and I realized I think I
was going in for a surgery that's for
Asian women
um possibly but I think with the the
bleff what they want to achieve these
girls what I'm seeing is like not just
the opening of the eye but they want a
slight kind of like Fox eye and I think
that's such a mistake because when
people have like what I call Sunshine
eyes and downturn it makes them look so
much sweeter and more likely yeah it's
like a um Ultra Hepper right yeah like a
the Almond eye yeah yeah like it's just
so innocent I just left there and was
like I can't believe how [__] stupid
and desperate I am to be like other
people that I went in for a surgery that
makes no sense your eyes are perfect
also literally yeah I Esther you have
gorgeous like big gorgeous eyes yeah me
you have the already eye like just
maybe I'll take my bananas today
feeling good
but isn't that such a weird thing like
you like the beauty standards are so
drastically different like you like I
watched this show called singles Inferno
and it's like a Korean dating show and
there's always one girl like okay most
of the girls are very
cute sweet soft Angelic looking but
there's always one girl who's like
Beautiful by American Standards like she
has like curves body lips slightly
Tanner and the guys never choose her and
I always think to my head oh my God if
she wasn't an American show she would be
like the number one yeah that was me I
had a boyfriend in middle school and a
Hebrew houses me because he's like oh uh
your Skin's too dark I can't tell my
friends you're my boy you're my
girlfriend so tell them I'm your
boyfriend okay I don't know like why
would you leave me
like mess you up it doesn't mess me up I
I was trying I tried to use the skin
bleach product in the summer I try to
use the blade to shave my skin so I can
look whiter because my mom said you
should wear long sleeve I was like you
can't wear pink you should cover up the
ugliness because I mean she's not wrong
because if I don't cover our people like
oh you are too dark to wear any color so
I was so afraid to wear pink wear bright
color it's just being dark in China it's
just it's awful like it's also it's it's
actually IOD like if you are drunk in
China you won't be you'll be getting
pregnant nobody's gonna touch you it's
disgusting it's awful and now I love my
skin now so I think I'm a lot of Asian
girl look at me and look at how
confident I am they're just like oh my
God I I I can be a dark Asian girl and
still feel pretty but it's just so
important because I had this job
interview in China for this TV show I
play the lead actress she's from America
she went back to take over her family's
business speak English
they they are giving me the IV treatment
to bleach my skin like you you have the
chemical get into your veins get into
blood and make your skin lighter they're
like you lose you have to lose 40 pounds
30 pounds maybe but you uh your face too
big so we're gonna do the haircut like
this and curve it inside so it covers
your face you have v-shape like Azure so
you can look pretty and then the record
but you have you'll have to do the
bleaching because I'm like she's from
she went to America for 10 years she's
American Chinese like how about she
she's like a Beyonce JLo 10 dude like
you are like like a Latino girls black
girls they are gorgeous at hand but
Asian girl is ugly when you are 10. so
they were like you can't you are not
convincing as a leading lady you can be
the Savage because you are so dark [__]
so I I try to bleach my skin I just
can't do it I'm like I'll be a fraud
I'll be a skinny bleached [__] fraud
all the Chinese girls they look at me
they're like oh I have to lose 40 pounds
and bleach myself to be joining Summers
I'm I'm like no
so I I quit a job because I just left I
came back to the open Mac here so if I
don't make it in comedy [__] you guys
I can be a British [__] okay okay the
world is so confusing because here you
guys are like and obviously that's like
a lot of people know that like talking
about like the you know it's better to
have lighter skin whatever literally my
whole childhood I was so [__] ashamed
of being pale I was so insecure I was
made fun of oh my God have you ever been
in the sun like you're Gothic it's just
it doesn't matter like you can be
anything and still be an ugly ass [__]
to somebody yes yeah so it's like if you
feel like an ugly ass [__] on this side
of the world go to the other side of the
world yes it's a location you are not
hot yeah you are hot every somewhere
yeah
location get a passport it's so true and
it's a trial and error thing the next
place you go they might be like we don't
want you either then keep moving keep
moving just go full circle it's across
the board true yeah it's so true
what a revelation It's Five O'Clock
Somewhere like you are hot somewhere you
are hot somewhere
[Laughter]
so you came here when you were 18 alone
by myself I I got on the plane I went to
Kentucky you know that's right
yeah but people don't get like wait I'll
give you a question yeah so you were
just a young girl in China and you were
like you looked at a map in America and
you were like Kentucky that sounds about
right yeah nobody lies about going to
Kentucky you know that's the best of us
like I
I'm just my mother finally agreed for me
to come to America I want to do acting
in China and the teacher won't let me on
stage today you're a tree stuff like you
you can play the the Brown family goat
like
yeah you can't be honest in Wonderland
you could be the tree stuff she stayed
up so I was like you know like a tree
stop but she sit on my back I
and then I started watching you know
Hollywood movies Halle Berry is gorgeous
she's a star like we have beautiful dark
woman obviously everybody thinks they
are hard why can't I be pretty I want to
come to America and my mom's like are
you gonna play for your own school so I
applied for 40 schools I got my first
offer from Kentucky you need a visa yeah
offer to get you a Visa I'm like I'm
gonna go from China to Kentucky and go
Kentucky
somewhere in New York so I just thought
I'm going to America I just don't want
her changing her mind so I just want to
Kentucky so you went to school in
Kentucky yeah and um you moved to the
east coast first I I actually I came
into uh California and Los Angeles 2013.
okay yeah after school I came here
that is so interesting what was your
experience as obviously like a Chinese
immigrant in Kentucky I to be honest the
racist people towards me were a Chinese
guy like it's a there's like a big wet
Karen lady but like Ming lady the people
are so nice in Kentucky they're like
oh can you talk
I'm like I'm not a sex doll yeah is it
every single Asian person is it like
you are exotic I'm like honey I'm not
exotic I made in China everything's made
in China underwear is made in China you
are exotic you are 400 pounds you're
from Kentucky honey I relax
um I'm everywhere there's more of me
than all over you like all the way guys
I think there's more Chinese women than
all white guys yeah for sure yeah I'm
like I'm not exotic but they were just
the nice people they just they are
curious like you can talk you can move
your pussy's not sideways I'm like
please don't eat my dog
we were nice but I had this this guy oh
I was working in this Japanese
restaurant like when you don't have a
green card you know you have to work the
shitty jobs I was working in the
Japanese restaurant the owner's Chinese
and he's like very bad to me I like I'm
like we are the only two Chinese person
in Kentucky like you don't have to be
bad he's like I want to send this shift
he's like if you eat my spring roll you
have Sunday shift oh my God I can really
I'm like are you kidding me I know
exactly what you're talking about when
my mom first um worked here or when he
first moved here she had to work under
the table as like a caretaker and she
had Filipino bosses and I'm telling you
guys like she made if let's suppose
minimum wage was seven dollars then they
probably paid her like two bucks an hour
and she took it because she was like you
know this is It's you know like I have
to take the job I have to save money but
it's almost the people who who are
familiar to you you who are going to
maybe like use youth in the worst way oh
my God that is I'm not it's so true it's
like a Candace Owens trying to speak on
behind black people she's Karen in
blackface right I'm like are you kidding
me you don't represent black people shut
the [__] up [__] like I'm so tired of
that [__] she
is just so dumb yeah like that is my
takeaway whenever I see a clip of her
I'm like you're not smart bro like
you're stupid I I see everything is like
in the same way I see Miss Universe
putting the Philippines in they're
gorgeous but it's always a money play I
always just think it's a money play yeah
she's acting yeah acting a role yeah
she's acting I think so too I think
everything is a money play it's like you
know canceled comedians they'll go
completely right you know be like they
lean into they lean into like the
conservative ideals now and but that's
still all of it is just the money play
yeah but don't you have to like sort of
believe that and be it a little bit I
don't know like I know what you're
saying so it's like if you say it enough
it's like you can almost believe the own
lies you tell yeah so maybe there's a
part of her that's like so [__]
warped because she's had to regurgitate
so much [__] for a long time that
she becomes it and really believes it so
maybe but yeah she does whenever I see
her speak it feels like a bad Act ding
kind of thing yeah like I'm pretending
to be like this I don't know
I don't know her makeup is good it is
pretty good yeah she's not ugly I'll say
that she knows she's a gorgeous girl
penny
Okay so
I I I'm asking these questions I hate
when people like so when did you start
stand up all of these things but like I
think your story is like incredibly
interesting because like truly like it's
hard enough to do stand up it's another
thing to have like an accent barrier
um and
all of the things that come with like
English not being like your first like
language right it's so tough yeah I have
to say moving to La by myself from
Chicago at 21 was terrifying and scary
and like life-altering
but you came from a different country
that's [__] crazy it's hard so hard
it's I I just I believe in myself uh I
feel like coming here uh having my
accent it just helped me to to be me and
help girls who look like me to be like
[__] all of you
that's what I'm trying okay yeah stand
up is just but like was there ever like
did you ever second guess yourself like
you came here in 2013 so that was a
whole 10 years ago I failed in acting I
would say mainly because of my accent my
acting was great I went to Harvard fine
I was very well trained actress I I got
audition I got called back it's my
accent they don't want it and like like
a fresh report like they would have
constantly she's from [__] Virginia
I'm from the boat
somebody who are who have a white accent
who can put on a fake Chinese accent
they don't want the real fake like we
want a real accent right be no shade to
Constance rule but like I think that if
we were to have stayed true to the book
that Eddie Wong wrote you would have
been the one cast yeah and also like
when people tell me I look at her I'm
like
somebody make sure she's way harder than
me were you just like scared or would
you just say you were really just
motivated because you didn't have time
to figure it out so how can I make it
this is me love you long a lot of time
accident is not gonna go away so what do
I do like who should I [__] to the
middle like then I realized that oh
I was at the audition there's nothing
sexual about this one John Singleton saw
me auditioning for his TV show uh Rebel
is is a role called um it's a Chinese
girl she's a sidekick her name is karma
I I got I got called back I got very far
but but I remember like I forgot the
line I started improvising he started
laughing so hard and he walked over to
me he's like you should do stand up
you'll be a star while he's playing Ali
wants baby cobra especially on his
iPhone you should you are going to be a
star I said you just poked me he's like
a girl I'm Gonna Be a Star I'm gonna go
do I have the role now he's like hell no
you're from San Francisco chair girl no
what do you mean he's like open mic
oh wow and then you just did it he got
my number I'm like I cried I'm like
that's it I failed it then I went to
China and I got offered for this show to
be a British [__] I'm like I can't
bleach my skin so I came back I'm like
let's find a rich husband and let's go
back to L.A and do stand up so I just
came here I started doing my Open Mic I
found out there's no stage time for
anybody I'm like oh let me buy a club so
I bought the club on Melrose
you did yeah it's like a one for the 60
60 hard place to do comedy in L.A is I'm
Melrose kawanga is in large mountain I
bought the club I'm like in days four I
don't know like his first month doing
stamina there's not enough time for me
to get better so I bought a club I've
been doing 10 hours a day every day then
the pandemic came I'm like I need to I
need to be good at all I do so I sold my
Birkin bags to pay the rent and then I
just started telling my jokes on Tick
Tock while vomiting because I was
pregnant with my daughter I'm like let
me get in one daughter because this is
one year I can't be not productive so
holy [__] so I got a daughter at the
club and I got many followers and then
[__] okay so recap you went to audition
he liked you but he didn't want to give
you the rule because of your accent he
said Do stand up and you said holy [__]
there aren't any open mics there's no
stage time so you bought a club yeah
America was called the Hollywood comedy
and you still have it oh yeah it's
packed every day it's so busy I I just I
I need to I I I'm gonna go I'm being the
Chinese here okay how old do I just got
better I want to be better at it you
know like get on stage every day as long
as you can I'm like wow I have to wait
for three hours for them to pull the
[__] drink from like the tickets it's
like a lottery it's just it's [__]
when you were nobody there's no no
search for you right I'm buying my own
stage I bought it like in one week and I
I bought it in one week and I have my
contractor fixed up and took him a week
and a half if I hired a Chinese would be
fast it was a Taiwanese guy so
this guy you can't say like hurry up
hurry up you know you're so sorry
who wants to be political about
everything
I was like I wish I had it I'm a Chinese
man yeah he'll be like try to hurry up
yeah
yeah and all the while I imagine you
just kept it pushing even throughout
pregnancy you were like I'm nauseous but
I'm gonna do it I realized that my
manager wasn't working I met my marriage
wasn't working and the marrying a rich
guy wasn't it for me to just stay home
was he Rich he was so rich that is
discussing I don't have his money I'm
I need a Xanax
but if freedom is worth it yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's like it's kind of like
it's like money helps it does money
money can make you happier but it
doesn't prevent you from being sad and
sometimes you get the big sads and
there's no amount of money you can throw
on that at all and certainly not even
from like a a freaking like a partner
especially so hard he didn't want me to
do it we fight every day when we go out
to do the open mic and I come home you
know conservative Chinese men from
Shanghai I come home at 11 30 he's like
do you know what kind of woman come home
with their boots and makeup and perfumes
the prostitutes and a horse
I can't believe you are saying this to
me I'm the mother of your children like
I'm your wife okay I'm not a [__]
because they make money I pay five
dollars for open mic
if I was a [__] I will be doing well
you know like I would financially
financially I'll be um I'll I'll own
only fans like I would be good
but it's just like you want to do this
you just have to be good at it and you
also have to sell tickets so I said I'm
gonna become famous on internet I'm
gonna share my jokes there I just keep I
posted four times a day every day even
though I was hugging the toilet throwing
up with the baby I was posting my
delivering room I'm like push push
pause this one okay I'll Crush my leg
until I push it I mean push
push I have to make it I have to because
I know we are gonna end a divorce and I
know like he's gonna punish me not give
me any money and I need to find out how
do I how do I be on my own I also I want
the kids so I want to be able to pay for
everything so I'm just like I have no
plan B I mean I didn't take any so I
don't I have to make it there's a better
one than Plan B anyways yeah we're Julie
supporters it's a new
um morning after pill or being a female
comedian nobody's gonna [__] you
yeah yeah in the morning after pill yeah
tell me about it
I always like to remind people because
we know that like the morning after pill
is so sad when you have to buy it and
it's like locked up in a cage
and like so that's why we like this
brand Julie because they make it feel
like
it's just normal and hot it's a hot girl
purchase yeah oh wow awesome yeah it's
like a purple box with like pink
typography and you're like hey I love
like it's okay to be a [__] yes yes so
that's our I love slots me too I don't
like there's a thing Chinese Chinese
green tea [__]
green tea [__] they are like they they
are a lot like us but like they were
like I would never suck a dick we can
smell the dick from like six feet away
I would never wear the hats that's just
like too much like I would have never
known as Meghan Markle but it's just the
worst she's an example of a green tea
[__] yeah I think she's I think she's
out of hair the league obviously she's
beautiful she's smart just tell me
you'll love attention God damn it don't
say you want a private life you don't
yeah I think so I think she got shot to
the Moon way too fast in such a short
amount of time yeah
and that's too much for I think anybody
no matter how big your aspirations for
fame are I think that level of people
just following you yeah is like a
detriment to your yeah people always
just tell me I'm racist because I don't
like her I'm like I'm not racist we are
the same people attention seeking [__]
well I know what she's up to like if you
don't believe me I ask you one simple
question guys like if Harry wasn't a
prince he works uh like okay that's just
like a Home Depot Home Depot yeah you
look like a manager there clueless
um always high on banded wrong so I was
like
would Megan marry him it would make a
Mary it was pretty [__] Adidas the
actress Mega Mary uh ball Ginger wait do
you still have any Birkin bags left I
have a few left yeah I have I have a a
dozen
wow so they they yeah I I sold a lot as
a real real
yes I just I I don't I don't hate bro
people I really don't because I was
broke you know I had no money when I
come here work hard you can make money
if you want it's a good [__]
go to work be smart make money because
that's it's easy I came here with no
green card and nothing I just I was
cleaning old lady's ass because that's
the Craigslist job you can get like yeah
caretaker yeah my mom didn't give me
anything uh people always tell me how do
you know they took you to dumpster after
they tell me you're like are you sure
when I'm like uh why get a minus in
school they were like I did not bring
back some dumpster for eight minutes
like it's it's that's every day A minus
it might as well be a [__] F yeah
yeah just go just like but I just think
that like when I look at you I'm like
you're just a life strategist yeah you
have a plan and nothing will get in your
way and that's so [__] inspiring and
he wanted to tell them the single mom
with kids the kids can't stop you they
make you better they are your angels
uh mainly my son but
what I'm saying is like we led to
societies of divine like you have
children that's the end of your career
that's over it's over it's over it's not
we can make it not you know it's it's I
feel like you can do anything you want
if I can do even do it better than me I
have nothing yeah I'm that's what I've
always been scared of it's like you know
the idea that like even though
um like I'm gonna enjoy my child and
love my child there's always that
feeling that
um there is a certain like Liberty that
you have to kind of let go of you know
like you can you can still be a horror
but like you usually can't be obvious
about it you know yeah yeah low-key
[__] it has to be low-key the opposite
of green tea [__] yeah yeah you have to
be Loki and I understand like I'm a
single mom you know if I'm meeting you
for a date I will be [__] you so you
better fax your STD result to my office
wait do do you tell guys on my way to
the dinner like I didn't even know it
before I arrive at the dinner season
like there's something there's herpes
I'll cancel I'll leave okay so this is
what I I I've been trying to ask people
like for me my policy has always been if
I know we're gonna hook up immediately
like I asked for the test yes and I
think that some people find that a
little bit too like jarring and kind of
unsexy but like I just won't [__] you
otherwise like how do you Esther what
are your thoughts I think that's hot of
you I think it's like assertive and
almost dominant in a way and confident
to ask for that like I think that's a
that would like turn me on if yeah we're
both turned on that's a real Rihanna
move yeah okay so it's not like
off-putting then because like that's
just always been it's so important
though like I hate condoms like I I need
to make me too I I if I'm [__] you
you better be clean that's very yeah if
you're gonna be coming in my [__]
like it better you know it better be
pristine but also I wanted to ask you
like when you go on dates with men
um do you tell them right out the gate
like hey I'm a mom like and I'm a
devoted mom and I have a two-year-old
and a four-year-old yeah and I I know I
think it's working better if I am like
going on this with a single dad because
they I want that single dad to at least
have custody or half it's not like a
that I want him to be present to the
child so he understands how hard it is
to raise a child and how important when
I put my kids as a priority he didn't
freak out like a little [__] so how
else would I go let's also schedule a
play date because my son gets [__]
make sure there is a little Karen like
let's just make sure they are okay so
after the play date I'll be [__] you
wait is there an app for just single
parents I met it in a Chinese dating app
memo
oh my God this should be a movie about
Jewish Chinese which would be a Jewish
Chinese lesbian and getting married wait
why do our family like a big Greek
Wedding the bigger Chinese wedding okay
your mom meeting my mom where she just
ordered Chinese you want to eat my
daughter too why do
um Jewish people [__] you right the
Chinese Mama Jewish mom yeah because you
remember my daughter is an angel my my
daughter's a dirty hoe you know they are
the Jewish mom in love with your
daughter the Chinese daughter is
disgusting you know what not fun not
only are you hot somewhere but you are
loved somewhere yeah you know so I think
that Esther you may not be loved in your
household but in her household is gonna
love you why can't you be like every
morning you hear why
why she's a movie star what are you
you're wearing a star jacket she's gonna
say that why can't you be like that's a
very Chinese thing to say Asian thing
right why can't you be your cousin
yeah you know bad [__] I would be so
jealous of you around my parents because
I know that they would find you so funny
oh and they don't think I'm funny my mom
doesn't think I'm funny
oh oh my God what up what a uh do they
do that I know they do like wife swaps
do they do children swap we should do
children swap as a movie yeah you live
with the Chinese Mom this is my dream
yes I go to the Jewish Family yeah my
Jewish mom telling me how beautiful I am
although I don't have a Jewish mom so
it's like but my Jewish dad was dead
yeah maybe too much that's funny yeah I
think that um but not like young kids
like adults yeah form like broken adults
yeah broken adults well my dream is to
be re-raised by Dave's parents because
he's like a normal person and whenever I
go to their house I'm just like I love
to pretend that like they're my parents
and they're so cute that is really cute
yeah I there I always say like yeah
they're my new parents now oh that's
beautiful oh you guys well this has been
swelling thank you so much thank you
really fit in with us oh my dear this
was so fun we love you so much you have
like honestly like you're a [__]
inspiration you're a badass [__] you're
just as shiny as your jacket on the
inside thank you so much also my [__]
is also shiny
smart and funny oh thank you so much
it's hard to be funny in a second
language yeah that's really [__] hard
it's not very easy yeah I
you're very smart I hope so and you're
[__] nailing it thank you and you're
incredible and you please come back and
I would love to come back whenever I've
come back anything I can leave my house
I love you so much and you guys thank
you so much for listening and we will
see you next week with a brand new
episode bye bye bye
[Music]
all right